boy look at that frame mark six six two
ten great size so he's gonna be able to
guard he's gotta check
uh pompeiro here that's a problem that's
a big time problem defensive end but
he caught a mouse in the house
difference of four and a half inches mr
poncaro showing off crawford the
christie jason terry
nate robinson
list goes on and on and here's the
latest addition vanquiero dente murray
in that crowd as well
vancaro with another
little bit of room service at the other
end
okay
we're in vegas so we'll take some show
time
he'll be here all week
showing exactly why
competing on the defensive end
a little flair why not it's vegas
[Music]
knocks down the second free throw
six-point game
let's watch him move his feet here
against vancaro
apollo got a step
and got the layup
and let's pray that they continue to
play about four or five games
vancaro trying to turn the corner picked
up by ellis boy
man
spinning like a dj
what a move by banker
so quickly
my goodness she ellis that's no
averaging over 60 million per
on the two-year deal
nice nice pass by bankero
houston vancouver gets it back shot
clock at three got to get busy with it
tough turnaround cash it's a screen for
ellis
[Music]
ellis gets the ball
lob and cada had it knocked away by
bankero but a foul was called on the
play
the number one pick in the draft against
the number four pick
that carroll
inside terry
got it game over
time to go home
the magic
win bacara almost gets stripped again
finds a way to get the ball back how
about the delivery
wow